so our next speaker is Lee Hellman
who
art history at the Graduate Center the
City University of New York and
specializing in 20th century art with a
particular interest in the study of
landscape and place she's currently
completing her dissertation which is
entitled staking ground the London
landscapes of Frank Auerbach and Leon
coast of 1950 to the present her
writings have appeared in the Burlington
magazine Apollo Tate papers and the
Brooklyn rail and in 2014 she
contributed a catalog essay for the
exhibition and muenster Germany entitled
bare life
London artists working from life 1950 to
1980 please join me in welcoming I
realize I forgot to make a cover slide
but the title of my paper is kindred
spirits of place Charles birch field and
Paul Nash so I start with two paintings
completed the same year 1943 the coming
of spring by the American painter
Charles birch field and landscape of the
vernal equinox by the British painter
Paul Nash obviously they're both
landscapes of sorts images of rural
nature although it's clear fairly
quickly that any topographical fidelity
has been refracted through a quirky and
reshaping graphic graphic vision we
might notice the symmetries and
opposition's at play in both
compositions Burchfield presents two
ravines one on the right and shadow with
the frozen waterfall and a lighter one
with green growth and a rushing stream
on the left in the Nash a white moon and
a red Sun hover in the sky on either
side of two rounded tree topped Hills
the compositional diagrams both
paintings could be drawn as an X more or
less around whose composition around
whose crossing point these oppositional
forces revolve I'll have more to say
about these two paintings shortly
unpacking some of the curious logic
underpinning their compositions is one
of my aims in this paper but I also want
to consider the year if they're making
1943 or the Year its completion in birch
fields unusual case what if anything do
these two paintings have to do with the
world defining war underway when they
were painted what correlations come to
light when we look at these odd
landscapes produced an ocean apart
outside the categories of British
neo-romanticism and American regionalism
they're typically associated with
nation' Burchfield were almost exact
contemporaries of birth but their lives
and careers were as different as some of
their artistic inclinations all argue
were kindred nash was born in 1889 four
years before Burchfield but died
prematurely in 1946 at the age of 57
while Burchfield lived into the late
1960s to the more ripe age of 73 Nash
served as an official war artist in both
to Britain in both 20th century world
wars while Burchfield never travelled
out of America and made very few
references to either war or their impact
upon him the synchronicity of
imagination I'm proposing between the
artists is one of those cases where it's
really difficult to prove any direct
interaction I've identified several
international exhibitions where they
could have seen each other's work and
it's possible that they could have met
in New York when Paul Nash was passing
through and he was on the jury of the
Carnegie International Exhibition in
1931 but it's not my intention in this
paper to argue a case of artistic
influence in either direction but rather
to explore some of the fertile
confluences of their expressions of
nature in their words and images
separately and repeatedly Nash's and
birch fields paintings have been
described as visionary transcendental
and pantheistic at the same time their
work is fully grounded in the land and
its seasonal cycles as the springtime
titles of these two paintings suggests
both were prolific writers Nash as an
art critic and Burchfield kept a
remarkable journal for 57 years time and
again they described their preoccupation
with a spirit of place in ancient Rome
the genius low sigh was a place as
watchful Guardian but the concept has
long been used more broadly to refer to
a landscapes distinctive atmosphere Nash
and birch field both perceived the
genius of a landscape not only in its
concrete visual forms but also in its
text
weathers smells and sounds Nash claimed
in 1934 that that a genius low sigh is
the source the motive power was and
which animates English art if its
expression could could be designated I
would say it is almost entirely lyrical
Burchfield wrote as early as 1915 it
seems at times I should be a composer of
sounds not only rhythms and colors and
later he described his hope to recreate
such moods as fear of the dark
the feeling of flowers before a storm
and even to visualize the songs of
insects and other sounds in 1943
specifically Nash and Burchfield pushed
their formal language in unprecedented
directions towards its expressive aims
but before I go further into the
wisenhouse of their sensibilities in
that decade Dec that decade I want to
detour briefly back to some original
groundings
in 1938 Nash began an autobiography
called what she called outline sadly it
was never finished but from the
beginning he conceived it as a book
concerned quote mainly with my
encounters with places rather than
people the effect places have had upon
me and I upon places among his most
enduring original significant places was
a pair of chalk hills in Oxfordshire
called the Whitnall clumps the first
time he saw them in his youth he was
seized by their presence the way they
seemed to rise gently and silently out
of the landscape they were the hills we
saw in the 1943 painting just shown and
he gives us a view to the larger one in
this early watercolor from 1912
historically the hills were significant
long before Nash came along as evidenced
by the range of archaeological
earthworks scattered across them
including Bronze Age ditches and Iron
Age hill forts but Nash simply called
them the pyramids of my small world
birch fields or place was his boyhood
home in Salem Ohio where he lived in a
small house with his widowed mother from
the age as ages of five to twenty eight
he described it later as a dream world
of the imagination
yellow afterglow of 1916 depicts one of
the back alleys of the neighborhood both
his and Nash's paintings adopt that
loose
shape diagram even here with the Nash's
composition converging on the clump of
trees and birch fields on the central
telephone pole both of their landscapes
feel carefully measured and plotted Nash
marks every field boundary and the
hedgerow and birch field seems to have
pasted every path and grass strip of his
suburban alley both pictures capture a
change in the light a cloud passes
through Nash's sky casting a sweeping
shadow over half the hillside Burchfield
catches the moment when the Sun has
slipped below the horizon its last Ray's
strike the side of the clapboard house
while the trees and telephone poles
darken into silhouette mystery hangs in
the painted atmosphere of these quiet
unpeopled scenes as if in their silence
there's something to be discovered just
out of eyes and ears reach Nash's images
soon betrayed his eager saturation and
British romantic art and poetry
especially the eccentric worlds of
Wordsworth William Blake Samuel Palmer
and Dante Rosetti this early dark little
drawing pyramids in the sea Rhee
conceives the Whitnall clumps those
pyramids of his small world is to
Egyptian ate pyramids echoed by to
swelling waves to tiny palms on the
distant dunes take the place of the
English beech trees willfully esoteric
with a Blakey and cosmic scope the
drawing is an early attempt to express
what Nash later enigmatically called
equivalences birch field was also
explode exposed to Blake and Palmer
while a student at the Cleveland School
of Art in Ohio along with the modernist
innovations of Matisse and Kandinsky but
he always would under play his artistic
influences he more readily cited his
literary inspirations especially the
nature writings of the American
transcendentalist Emerson and Thoreau
birch fields artistic breakthrough came
in in 1917 a passage he later called his
golden year ostensibly the subject in
this brightly hewed watercolor is his
own family garden but the real theme is
the ecstatic animation of nature itself
like Palmer's garden in Shoreham the
forms of birch fields suburban garden
practically metastasized before our eyes
cascading flowers prolific
raiding woods and billowing clouds
engulfed the small gable fronted house
nature's vibrations spread out with it
with the dynamic simultaneity of a
futurist canvas by giacomo Bala
but the settings more like the jungles
of Omri Rousseau crossed with Alice in
Wonderland there's a hallucinatory
strangeness to both artist youthful
images to be sure a shared perception of
what Nash called the monstrous and the
magical monstrous of course doesn't
begin to describe what befell the
European landscape with the outbreak of
the first world war it's one of the
great paradoxes of Nash's career that he
experienced his mature breakthrough in
the paintings he made as an official war
artist for Britain in 1917 and 18 the
outrage and devastation he felt at what
he witnessed on the Western Front
catalyzed his most searing imagery yet
he painted we are making a new world
based on sketches of his visit to the
site of the Battle of Pass Khandala
Tuscan Dale known as the Third Battle of
Ypres Nash first painted the scene in
words in a letter to his wife Margaret
written immediately after his visit to
the site quote sunset and sunrise are
blasphemous there mockeries to man the
rain drives on the stinking mud becomes
more evilly yellow the shell holes fill
up with green white water the roads and
tracks are covered in inches of slime
the black dying trees booze and sweat
and the shells never cease it is
unspeakable godless hopeless I'm no
longer an artist who is interested in
curious I'm a messenger who will bring
back word from the men who are fighting
to those who want the war to go on
forever Burchfield meanwhile was still
buoyant in the creative flood of his
golden year when the war directly
interrupted his life - in 1918 he was
drafted into the American services and
spent six months at a camp in South
Carolina for training he never came
close to combat continued painting while
away from home and later denied that the
Great War had any effect on his art
whatsoever
it was far far away he wrote and I
rarely thought of it but was wrapped up
in my dreams and visions the first
hepaticus is one of the darker paint
from his golden year but it was a scene
no less beautiful to the artist for its
cold and monochromatic austerity he
wrote off engine of the of the visions
he experienced in those days of
ghost-like hostile trees and an
overpowering black presence a feeling of
forsaken miss grotesqueness of
Northwoods in the painting gnarly roots
intertwine forming a hard carpet over
the forest floor the black tree hollows
in the foreground gait like moaning
mouths while the wall the wood behind
them recedes into an eerie white fog in
the lower right a clump of small white
hepatica flowers one of springs first
telltale signs glows against the black
void of a root hollow most of the trees
and birch fields painting are simply in
dormancy ready to branch into new life
in the new season as fern ashes blasted
devastated would I show this historic
photograph of the battle site on the
lower left alongside this recent
photograph I came across as a shocking
reminder of how real Nash's vision of
the shelled landscape actually was and
how nearly a hundred years later
Europe's deforested landscape still
bears those scars I don't know if
Bertrille would have seen such wartime
photographs in the newspapers but the
near monochrome of his watercolor is
almost uncanny even for winter what I'm
struck by when I look at Nash's and
birch fields painting side by side is
the way they're linked not only in the
ugliness of their bare bare trees but
also in the way they fold a kind of
grief and hope into each other the
barely opened flowers in birch fields
bleak would pretend springs promise
mingle mingle dwith the bitterness of
Nash's title is the necessity of
endurance to the Sun still shines over
the wasteland in his painting the great
war's end found both artists struggling
to make a living from their art that was
financially and spiritually viable Nash
triptych calling himself a war artist
without a war despite birch fields
dismissal of the war's impact he too
experienced a crisis of confidence after
his discharge from the military in 1921
he moved to Buffalo New York where he
worked as a wallpaper designer for seven
years painting in the evenings and on
weekends
through the depression Burchfield
produced a steady stream of
predominantly urban and industrial
scenes entirely heavier and more still
of atmosphere than his than the feverish
dream world of his suburban of the Salem
Garden paintings such as winter Twilight
sold readily but Burchfield resisted his
categorization and to the discourses of
regionalism and American scene painting
with growing unease I'm not an Ohio or a
Western New York artist he wrote to his
dealer but an artist who happens to be
born living painting in America if I
paint for an audience it is to anyone
anywhere who happens to be spiritually
akin to me nasha also produced a series
of more straightforwardly pastoral
landscapes in the 1920s but by the end
of the decade he was fully swept up in
the forward lines of the British
avant-garde he flirted briefly with pure
abstraction but surrealism seduced him
more lastingly
in part because he recognized in it an
updated expression of the poetic vision
he believed to be native to British art
the prehistoric standing stones and
earthworks that had long fascinated him
were easily adapted into the new
surrealist idiom as inanimate objects
full of unseen vitality consider these
two paintings of 1929 and 1930 entirely
different and their respective realist
and surrealist idioms but linked at the
same time by a certain stillness a
melancholy and mystery reminiscent of
Georgia to Kirikou not to mention birch
fields good friend Edward Hopper it
would require another paper to tease out
the relations between objects in the
foreground of Nash's landscape here and
still we'd never know for sure the young
trees in his orchard line up it's been
suggested like soldiers like headstones
in a soldier's Cemetery in birch fields
paintings the storm clouds parked car
and people staring into an empty shop
window suggests a narrative but one
whose beginnings and endings retreat
firmly into the shadows in 1940 Nash
became an unofficial war artist for the
second time a vociferous supporter of
the fight against Nazism and fascism he
staked an enormous and frankly
uncritical faith in the prop
and a value of art he was initially
assigned to the air ministry during
during the Battle of Britain though he
never went up and into a plane due to
his severe asthma several of his early
World War two images - pitched crashed
German bombers their hulking metal bones
decomposing in the English cornfields
the Battle of Germany finished in 1944
is Nash's last and largest and most
uncompromising least range war painting
a semi abstracted calculation of what he
called the dreadful fantasy of airborne
warfare the view point is not just
aerial but cosmic drawing together field
plotted land astronomical bodies
vaporous clouds and the distant blue sea
the moon on the left is echoed by a
constellation of white round disks and
above that an off-white explosion as a
bomb or a plane crashes to earth the
central pillar of smoke expands into
black blue and red clouds not unlike not
unlike the ones Nash painted in 1918 s
we are making a new world the color
spectrum nash explained was designed to
conjure a chromatic percussion with one
purpose to suggest explosion and
detonation as the world was being torn
asunder Nash composed a battle of forces
violently in play Burchfield
initially shared the same isolationist
inclinations as the majority of
Americans although his journals reveal
his growing unrest about remaining
neutral there was never a question of
which side Burchfield was on but he also
never wavered in his belief that his
that his best and only contribution to
the war effort could be to carry out his
art independently after the United
States entered the war in 1941
Burchfield refused two opportunities to
contribute artwork in an official
military capacity he wrote in a similar
period Beethoven gave us his great
symphonies Sibelius wrote his fifth it
is up to the artist to take the
long-range view and create for peace it
is hard but I must somehow pull myself
out of this slough in 1943 while Nash
was conceiving of the Battle of Germany
Burchfield was struggling to
finish a painting of two ravines
remembering a watercolor he had made
earlier in his career he pulled it out
of a drawer and found himself startled
by the youthful brazenness of his
achievement looking at the early sheet
filled him with an urge he later wrote
to let myself go in fantasy as I had not
done since 1918 doing so seemed to
release something in me a long pent-up
subconscious yearning to do fanciful
things and once started it seemed to
sweep onward like a flooded stream there
was no stopping it
in fact so flooded was Burchfield
imagination that he ended up reworking
and enlarging the original composition
expanding it in order to accommodate his
expanding need in 1943 to let nature in
that's what we see now in the coming of
spring that I'm showing up to ten sheets
were added around the originals edges
and the whole thing reworked he
explained in his 1917 manner it subdued
this springtime fantasy compared to the
garden painting we saw earlier but look
carefully within its balance of light
and dark at how many ways the v-shape of
the two ravines is echoed in the meeting
of the streams in the water splashes in
the upward growing tree branches in the
squiggly leaves in the cartoony flying
bird just up in the upper left and in
the craggy antlers of the Fallen would
publicly litchfield later frame 1943 's
creative dam break in the entirely
solipsistic terms of his artistic
evolution making no reference to the
distant war but however you frame it
conflict is present in this image as
surely as it was present in the lives of
his friends and neighbors with sons and
brothers off fighting it is present here
in this locally imagined landscape
inherent in the dialectic of the two
ravines one showing the coming of spring
and the other clinging on to frozen
nature frozen winter what's remarkable
is the way the picture suggests this
natural conflict already in the process
of resolving itself on the clashing
brink between two seasons nature is
continuously self balancing ice slowly
melts from the dark ravine and a fresh
stream cascades
the other stump on the left bank is a
hollow ghost of a tree but new buds
sprout from the young one just by to
liberate his imagination Burchfield had
to go back to move forward he wrote in
his journal quote the very fact that
there seems little chance of selling
pictures until the war is over seems to
be a release to me and I feel free to
work on a picture like this I might as
well paint entirely for myself on the
surface there couldn't be a more gaping
disparity between birch fields fiercely
maintained independence and Nash's
eagerness to contribute to the war
effort but the war prompted an artistic
release for Nash - provoking him to an
equally acute reckoning of his
avocational purpose his hope to make
images that spoke to the present
conflict and which honored his personal
and private communion with nature
he realized did not have to be an
either/or proposition he came to this
realization when he liked Burchfield
found himself staring into his past
facing the two hills that had haunted
him since childhood in 1942 while
carrying out his war commissions Bert
Nash visited a friend whose property had
a large window overlooking the Whitnall
clumps as if bringing Nash's own distant
memories back into view the encounter
stimulated a culminating series of
paintings revolving around the site
which were not made in any official
capacity or related to the warm
landscape of the vernal equinox as one
of these paintings draws on all of his
previous imaginative investigations into
the synthesis of oppositional elements
Sun and Moon night and day winter and
spring blue and pink male and female
past and present youth and maturity are
among the possible duality is brought to
bear upon and around these mirrored
hills as if compelled to order the
cosmos itself Nash brings all of these
forces into a new and mysterious
equation the year after he completed the
coming of spring Burchfield returned to
another youthful image autumnal fantasy
subjecting it to to a wild expansion
here he really lets rip - birds sing to
each other their music resounding and it
stretched sonic
Camas from the tree from the tree knots
everything is simultaneous brought to a
crescendo of light and visual sound a
continent away
it was gunshots flying in all directions
and reverberations of falling bombs I'm
not suggesting that Burchfield was
thinking of the war let alone trying to
interpret or redeem it only that he's
given us here in his own cartoon
inspired notation a seriously clamorous
version vision of nature's music I'm not
saying that either of these paintings
are allegories of war but I'm suggesting
it would be equally mistaken to consider
them in their historical context as I'm
doing and conclude that they're escapist
fantasies they are fantasies to be sure
as Burchfield title fully owns but
they're fantasies of the life and death
of nature president every moment as my
friend Michael alig each of birch fields
dry falling leaves as my friend Michael
Rose is written shines with its own
dying
ground air water branch and sunlight
skies shaped with the consciousness of
their place in the mortal fabric war is
unbalanced but as the writer guide
Davenport writes in his brilliant essay
on Burchfield nature is self renewing
and perennial this was the hope at least
that gnashing Burchfield put their faith
in through the darkest days of their own
season so the genius low side we
perceive in their unquiet landscape
seems to be that of the artists own
encompassing spirit
you